véritable forme de littérature qui peu à
peu a franchi les siècles le compte
aujourd'hui survie non sans difficulté
face aux nouveaux médias et cette
semaine du conte se propose justement de
perpétuer cette littérature se savoir
populaire
par ailleurs au travers d'un concours de
dessin les enfants d'une quinzaine
d'écoles du cantal ont également apporté
leur contribution pour illustrer
différents contes et légendes et pour
les petits comme pour les grands soirs
et animations et spectacles se succèdent
exemple celui interprété par la
compagnie aurillacoise de la lune rousse
les trois écuries diane il était une
fois dans mon pays loin par delà les
montagnes un roi notre roi qui se
faisait beaucoup de soucis
oui
on veut absolument montrer que le compte
est encore vivant complètement et que
c'est un moyen essentiel de
communication dans la région
un moyen qui on attend ce permanent qui
tendait mais puisque on leur met à
l'honneur et ben ça s'agite partout et
puis s'il faut absolument que qu'on s'en
rende compte que ça existe et c'est que
c'est très important dans la mémoire et
que c'est actualisable et actualisée
aujourd'hui pour ce qui concerne la
pièce dont on déjà vu un extrait est ce
que ça correspond tout à fait à la
philosophie que voulait faire passer
cette semaine
complètement parce que d'abord c'est des
gens d'ici qui ont complètement crée
donc ce spectacle à partir d'un compte
ou auvergnat c'est trop chaud un peu
c'est trop pas imposer trop dur à tous
être homo à côté 38e la calèche retard
et toi même comme ça tu la trouveras ton
goût j'irai me coucher